hi could I ask my cinematographer Madeon
to come up and join me so the North Bay
fire swept through Northern California's
wine country during my first month of
grad school at the time it was the
deadliest natural disaster in
California's history they burned
uncontrolled for 23 days and we heard
story after story of the physical
devastation that they left behind but
what I heard less of were the stories of
those who live in the shadows of wine
country the 50,000 undocumented
immigrants who make up the backbone of
Napa and Sonoma as tourism and
agricultural industries because of their
immigration status they were left most
vulnerable after the fires when I set
out to make this film a year later it
was their story that I wanted to tell so
first and foremost I want to thank
Consuela Medrano who is a heroine in
this film and in her community in Napa
Gustavo Vargas and all of the people who
had to remain anonymous but were brave
enough to trust me with their story I'd
like to thank everyone at the UC
Berkeley Graduate School of Journalism
who made this film possible my advisers
Carrie Lozano Don Porter
Cassandra Herman Lauren caps Chris O'Day
and Mike Shen my fearless
cinematographer Mary Ann Curtis kettle
who made this film beautiful
and everyone in the 2019 documentary
class who provided endless feedback and
moral support thank you thank you to
Andrew ching jacob bloomfield miss ratch
and william Fritsch who composed the
music for the film and jim Labrecque and
berkeley sound artist whom artists who
mixed it I'd like to thank my parents
and my brother who are here tonight
thank you for believing me and
supporting me every step of the way and
last but not least I never thought I
would say this but thank you to pick out
of me thank you so much for this
incredible honor
[Applause]